Remember that big terrorism case back in 2003? The Detroit sleeper cell case?
还记得2003年那起重大的恐怖主义案件吗？底特律“沉睡者小组”案？
In Detroit tonight, closing arguments have ended and a jury is set to deliberate the first case against an alleged terror cell inside the US.
今晚在底特律，结案陈词已经结束，陪审团准备对美国境内首起针对所谓恐怖小组的案件进行审议。
This the first terrorism case after the September 11 attacks to go to trial. There were convictions, it was a big deal. And then something strange happened. The Justice Department-- the very institution that put these guys on trial in the first place-- went out and voluntarily asked the judge to reverse the convictions. They undid their own victory, and they didn't stop there. They turned around and brought criminal charges against the very guy who prosecuted their case, their own colleague.
这是“9·11”袭击事件后首起进入庭审的恐怖主义案件。当时有定罪，这曾是一件大事。但后来发生了一些奇怪的事情。司法部——当初把这些人送上法庭的机构——竟然主动要求法官撤销这些定罪。他们推翻了自己取得的胜利，而且还没到此为止。他们转过头来，对自己案件的检察官，也就是他们自己的同事，提起了刑事指控。
You're going to hear a lot about this prosecutor today. his name is Richard G. Convertino. He used to be a rising star at the Justice Department, with commendations from the Attorney General, the head of the FBI. He sent mobsters and drug gangs and white collar criminals to prison.
今天你们会听到很多关于这位检察官的事情，他的名字叫理查德·G·康韦蒂诺（Richard G. Convertino）。他曾是司法部冉冉升起的新星，受到过司法部长和联邦调查局局长的嘉奖。他曾将黑帮分子、贩毒集团成员和白领罪犯送进监狱。
Today we try to answer the question, what the hell happened? What could possibly happen that would make the US government overturn its own successful conviction and then go after its own prosecutor. We're devoting our whole show today to this story. It is This American Life from WBEC Chicago, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
今天我们试图回答一个问题：到底发生了什么？究竟发生了什么事，会让美国政府推翻自己成功的定罪，并转而去对付自己的检察官？我们今天整个节目都将专注于这个故事。这里是来自芝加哥WBEC的《美国生活》（This American Life），由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。
Petra Bartosiewicz has been covering terrorism prosecutions for a few years, this one included and she tells her story.
佩特拉·巴托谢维奇（Petra Bartosiewicz）几年来一直在报道恐怖主义起诉案件，包括这一起，她将讲述她的故事。
So what kind of prosecutor was Rick Convertino? Well, that depends on who you ask. ,
那么，里克·康韦蒂诺是那种什么样的检察官呢？嗯，那得看你问谁了。
He was relentless. He was just an excellent prosecutor.
他毫不留情。他是个非常出色的检察官。
I really think Mr Covertino is fooling everybody, even his wife and he is a devil.
我真的认为康韦蒂诺先生在欺骗所有人，即使是他的妻子，他是个恶魔。
Rick was sought after. He got things done.
里克很受追捧。他总能把事情办成。
He had the reputation, at least in the legal community, of someone not to be trusted.
至少在法律界，他的名声是不值得信任的人。
Call me when you hear him admit to a mistake, would you, please?
当你们听到他承认错误时，请给我打个电话，好吗？
Here's some of the undisputed facts about Richard G. Convertino. For the 16 years he was a federal prosecutor, he loved standing in front of juries and declaring that he represented the United States of America. He sometimes got to the office before dawn. He took on cases other attorneys wouldn't, stayed involved with victims and even sometimes the defendants after a case was over. But his supervisor told me that if you didn't see things Rick's way, you were a bum. And woe to the prosecutor Rick caught checking Michigan football draft picks on the internet, or slacking off in the break room.
以下是一些关于理查德·G·康韦蒂诺无可争议的事实。在他担任联邦检察官的16年里，他热爱站在陪审团面前，宣称自己代表美利坚合众国。他有时黎明前就到了办公室。他承接其他律师不愿接手的案件，在案件结束后仍与受害者甚至有时与被告保持联系。但他的上司告诉我，如果你不按照里克的想法看问题，你就是个废物。而且如果哪个检察官被里克发现在上网查看密歇根大学橄榄球队的选秀名单，或者在休息室偷懒，那可就惨了。
Rick traveled constantly for trials, even after he and his wife Valerie started having kids. He was away most of Val's second pregnancy, and was out working on a bank fraud trial the day she went into labor.
里克经常出差参加审判，即使在他和妻子瓦莱丽（Valerie）开始生孩子后也是如此。瓦莱丽第二次怀孕期间，他大部分时间都不在家，在她分娩那天，他还在处理一起银行欺诈案的庭审。
I had to drive my oldest daughter to the babysitter, and then I drove myself to the hospital. And he didn't get to see her till she was about two days old.
我不得不开车送大女儿去保姆那里，然后自己开车去了医院。直到她出生两天后，他才见到她。
He was gone for most of her third pregnancy too.
她在第三次怀孕期间，他也大部分时间不在家。
I thought he was doing the right thing. I kind of viewed his traveling as being similar to a military family, that the sacrifice that I was making was for my country as well, so that he could do his job.
我当时以为他在做正确的事。我把他的奔波看作和军人家庭一样，认为我所做的牺牲也是为了我的国家，这样他才能做好他的工作。
We thought the sacrifices we were making meant something, meant a lot. But in retrospect now, for me it's impossible not to be bitter.
我们曾以为我们所做的牺牲有意义，意义重大。但现在回想起来，我很难不感到苦涩。
It's conceivable that everything that happened to Rick and to the Detroit sleeper cell case comes down to office politics gone terribly awry. The office politics at the US Department of Justice are like the office politics anywhere else, except the stakes are higher. You know, justice. The story begins just six days after September 11. After the attacks on the World Trade Center and the Pentagon, law enforcement suddenly had this new directive: Stop the next attack. Catch the terrorists before they strike again.
可以想象，发生在里克和底特律“沉睡者小组”案上的一切，归根结底是办公室政治出了严重的问题。美国司法部的办公室政治和其他地方一样，只是赌注更高。你知道，是正义。故事始于“9·11”事件发生后仅仅六天。在世贸中心和五角大楼遇袭后，执法部门突然接到了一项新指令：阻止下一次袭击。在恐怖分子再次发动袭击前抓住他们。
Outside of Detroit, agents went out looking for number 27 on the FBI's terrorist watch list: Nabil Al-Marabh, a supposed associate of Osama Bin Laden. They ended up at Al-Marabh's last known address, a dumpy two-story house in Dearborn.
在底特律郊外，特工们开始寻找FBI恐怖分子观察名单上的第27号人物：纳比勒·阿尔-马拉布（Nabil Al-Marabh），据称是奥萨马·本·拉登的同伙。他们最终找到了阿尔-马拉布最后的已知住址——迪尔伯恩市一栋破旧的两层楼房。
The front door had the the name Nabil Al-Marabh on it. An FBI agent knocked on the door and down came one of the defendants, Karim Koubriti, to answer the door.
前门上写着“纳比勒·阿尔-马拉布”的名字。一名联邦调查局特工敲了门，其中一名被告卡里姆·库布里蒂（Karim Koubriti）下楼来应门。
I just came back from work, and I was taking a shower. Then I'm done with the shower. I heard a knock on the door, and somebody calling Nabil, Nabil, Nabil. So I went down to see, because they were knocking hard. So they asked me for my ID. I was in my bath stuff, so I don't have my ID on, so I was like, I'm going to go upstairs to get it. As soon as I turn, they follow me.
我刚下班回来，正在洗澡。洗完澡后，我听到敲门声，有人在喊“纳比勒，纳比勒，纳比勒”。所以我下楼看看，因为他们敲得很重。他们问我要证件。我当时还穿着洗澡的东西，所以没带证件，我就说，我要上楼去拿。我刚一转身，他们就跟了上来。
During the protective sweep, they find two airport identification badges for Detroit Wayne County Airport.
在保护性搜查中，他们发现了两张底特律韦恩县机场的机场身份证明徽章。
I used to work in a company called Sky Shift. This company provided food for airplanes. We were fired because we had a car accident and we didn't go for two days, so they fired us. But nobody told us to turn over the badges, so they were thrown on the table.
我曾经在一家叫“天空轮班”（Sky Shift）的公司工作。这家公司为飞机提供食物。我们因为出了车祸没去上班两天被解雇了，所以他们解雇了我们。但没人叫我们上交徽章，所以它们被扔在了桌子上。
And then they were asked about their work history, and none of them mentioned the airport, which caused concern.
然后他们被问及工作经历，他们都没提到机场，这引起了怀疑。
And as soon as they see that Metro Airport, everything changed, like we lied to them or something like that. And the FBI guy was real hard. "Why are you lying to me?" I was like, "Lie to you about what?"
当他们看到大都会机场的东西时，一切都变了，好像我们对他们撒了谎之类的。那个FBI的人真的很强硬。“你为什么要对我撒谎？”我说，“对你撒什么谎？”
So they were placed in handcuffs and the agents asked for permission to search the apartment.
于是他们被戴上了手铐，探员们要求搜查公寓。
Because I just came to the country-- it was like 10 months-- I don't even speak the language. I don't know, I think I thought it was like a regular thing. In the beginning, that's how I think about it, you know? It wasn't a big deal. When they pulled their guns out, I was a little upset.
因为我刚到这个国家——才10个月——我甚至都不会说这种语言。我不知道，我想我以为这只是正常的事情。起初，我是这么想的，你知道吗？这没什么大不了的。当他们拔出枪时，我有点心烦。
During the search of his room, Koubriti told the agents they'd find some fake documents there-- a fake passport, fake social security card, blank birth certificates-- which they did. Then out of a small closet one of the agents pulled down a black suitcase. In its side pocket she found a day planner. Koubriti told the FBI that none of this stuff was his, that it belonged to an ex-roommate. It all looked bad, but the day planner was by far the most disturbing thing the agents found.
搜查他的房间时，库布里蒂告诉探员，他们会在那里发现一些伪造文件——假护照、假社保卡、空白出生证明——事实也确实如此。然后，一名探员从一个小壁橱里拿出一个黑色手提箱。在侧袋里，她发现了一本日程本。库布里蒂告诉FBI，这些东西都不是他的，属于以前的一个室友。这一切看起来都很糟，但日程本绝对是探员们发现的最令人不安的东西。
Flipping through the pages, they saw suspicious looking sketches, simplistic drawings of what looked like airplanes flying into some kind of objects, and then what looked to be an explosion. Remember, this was less than a week since the collapse of the World Trade Center.
翻阅页面时，他们看到了可疑的草图，那看起来像飞机撞向某种物体的简化图，然后看起来像是爆炸。记住，这距离世贸中心倒塌还不到一周。
So Rick started to put together this very unusual kind of case. He sorted through the evidence from the apartment trying to figure out, not what had happened, but instead, what was maybe going to happen. He says he showed the day planner to intelligence experts.
于是里克开始整理这起非常不寻常的案件。他梳理了公寓里的证据，试图弄清楚的不是发生了什么，而是可能会发生什么。他说他把日程本展示给了情报专家。
This page, as interpreted by the Air Force, was that there were three types of aircraft fighter planes-- the F 16s, the refueling planes--
这一页，按照空军的解读，是有三种类型的战斗机——F-16、加油机——
At first glance, this sketch might look like a drawing your kindergartner would do. But if you stare at it a minute or two, you begin to wonder why your kindergartner would draw the three kinds of American planes enforcing the no fly zone over northern Iraq. It's crude, but you can understand what's so troubling about it. The words American base in Turkey are written at the top. The US does have a single air base in the Middle East, in Turkey, in the town of Incirlik.
乍一看，这张草图看起来像是你幼儿园孩子画的。但如果你盯着它看一两分钟，你就会开始好奇，为什么你幼儿园的孩子会画出这三种强制执行伊拉克北部禁飞区的美国飞机。虽然粗糙，但你可以理解它有什么令人不安的地方。页面顶部写着“土耳其的美军基地”。美国在伊斯兰教地区，即土耳其的因吉利克（Incirlik）镇，确实有一个空军基地。
The sketch shows what looks to be three stick figure planes, each drawn slightly differently-- lined up at the end of a runway-- and a squiggly blob on the lower left that some Air Force experts said might have represented a hardened bunker.
草图显示了看起来像是三架火柴人画的飞机，每一架画得略有不同——排在跑道末端——左下角有一个蜿蜒的斑点，一些空军专家说这可能代表一个加固的地堡。
So when this was seen by the Office of Special Investigations in the United States Air Force, it was taken very seriously. And their flight patterns were altered and the base was-- I believe it was temporarily shut down. Because of this crude sketch that your four-year-old daughter might be able to do, the Air Force believe that an attack was diverted.
所以当美国空军特别调查办公室看到这张图时，他们非常重视。他们的飞行航线被改变了，基地被——我相信是暂时关闭了。因为这张你四岁的女儿可能都能画出的粗糙草图，空军认为一场袭击被阻止了。
While he was preparing for the trial, Rick went to turkey to see Incirlik for himself. He went on to the roof of a nearby bakery that overlooks the runway, the same vantage point the Air Force said the sketch was drawn from.
在准备审判时，里克亲自去了土耳其，想亲眼看看因吉利克。他走到附近一家俯瞰跑道的面包店屋顶上，那就是空军所说草图绘制的同一观察点。
And there was a rickety ladder and there was a rain pipe and there was a rope. So I climbed up, I had the sketch in my hand, and I looked out across that field and I saw what was depicted on that sketch. I saw those three types of planes. I saw what was referenced as the hardened bunker to the lower left. So that sketch became real to me.
那里有一个摇摇欲坠的梯子，还有一根雨水管和一根绳子。所以我爬了上去，手里拿着草图，向那片场地望去，我看到了草图上描绘的东西。我看到了那三种类型的飞机。我看到了被称为左下角加固地堡的东西。所以那张草图对我来说变得真实了。
This was exactly what the Attorney General wanted prosecutors all over the country to be looking for. A would-be terrorist plot in the making, and then we were lucky to capture them when we did.
这正是司法部长希望全国各地的检察官去寻找的东西。一个正在酝酿中的恐怖分子阴谋，我们很幸运在他们动手时抓住了他们。
This is Jeffrey Breinholt. These days he works at a national security think tank. He's on leave from the Justice Department, where he was a top official in the terrorism and violent crime section in Washington. He was one of the people supervising the Detroit sleeper cell case. Current Justice Department officials in Washington wouldn't talk to us for this story. It was Breinholt's job to develop these brand new kinds of terrorism cases-- preemptive prosecutions-- where you charge the bad guys with the crime before they hurt anyone. So here Rick's case comes along.
这位是杰弗里·布莱恩霍尔特（Jeffrey Breinholt）。如今他在一家国家安全智库工作。他正在从司法部休假，此前他是华盛顿恐怖主义和暴力犯罪部门的高级官员。他是监督底特律“沉睡者小组”案的人员之一。华盛顿的现任司法部官员拒绝就这个故事接受我们的采访。布莱恩霍尔特的工作是开发这些全新的恐怖主义案件——预防性起诉——即在坏人伤害任何人之前就以犯罪指控他们。所以里克的案件就来了。
It was one of the major early cases of our testing, both our laws and our new philosophy, and we wanted to make sure it got done right. And we had to make sure that it wasn't an embarrassment.
这是我们测试法律和新理念的早期重大案件之一，我们要确保它做得对。我们必须确保它不会成为一件尴尬的事。
This would be just about the last time Rick and his bosses in DC would see eye to eye on the case.
这将是里克和他在华盛顿的老板们在案件上意见一致的最后时刻了。
Four men in Detroit were charged with conspiring to provide information to terrorists for a series of attacks on the US and overseas.
底特律的四名男子被指控密谋向恐怖分子提供信息，以对美国和海外进行一系列袭击。
As the arrests began to get attention, Rick felt that the higher ups in DC were messing with his case. Someone inside the department leaked the details of the government's case to Fox News before the grand jury had signed off on it-- a huge no no.
随着逮捕行动开始受到关注，里克感到华盛顿的高层在干扰他的案件。司法部内部有人在陪审团签署之前，就把政府案件的细节泄露给了福克斯新闻（Fox News）——这可是个大忌。
Fox News correspondent Catherine Herridge reports.
福克斯新闻记者凯瑟琳·赫里奇（Catherine Herridge）报道。
A Michigan grand jury has handed up an indictment against four men, including Karim Koubriti, Ahmed Hannan--
密歇根州的一个大陪审团已经对四名男子提起诉讼，其中包括卡里姆·库布里蒂、艾哈迈德·汉南（Ahmed Hannan）——
The judge on the case, Gerald Rosen, was peeved as well. He wouldn't go on the record for this story, but he talked about it at a recent terrorism forum.
该案的法官杰拉尔德·罗森（Gerald Rosen）也很恼火。他不会公开就这个故事发表评论，但他曾在最近的一个恐怖主义论坛上谈到过。
I saw this when I was watching the evening news and the political correspondent of one of the networks was reading the indictment before the grand jury had issued it. And needless to say, that was disturbing. By the way, I also found out that I had the case when I was watching the evening news. They showed a picture of the indictment on the screen with my name on it.
我是在看晚间新闻时看到这一幕的，某个电视网的政治通讯员在陪审团发布之前就在宣读起诉书。不用说，这令人不安。顺便说一句，我也是看晚间新闻时才知道这案子归我的。屏幕上显示着起诉书的照片，上面有我的名字。
From Rick's point of view, it wasn't helpful for them to be irritating the judge before they even began. To top it off, the judge had issued a gag order on the case, meaning no one was supposed to talk about it. But then the Attorney General himself, John Ashcroft, violated it, not once, but twice during the case, saying things that didn't match the facts. Here's Rick.
从里克的角度来看，还没开始就惹恼法官对他们毫无帮助。最糟糕的是，法官对案件发出了封口令，这意味着任何人都不许谈论它。但随后司法部长约翰·阿什克罗夫特（John Ashcroft）本人在案件审理期间违反了该命令，不是一次，而是两次，说出的话与事实不符。这是里克。
We were asked if-- I was asked if our case had any connection with September 11 or any of the individuals who are involved in September 11. And there was absolutely no connection that I saw, or that anyone who was working the case saw, and we said that. And then there was-- an artificial connection was made publicly by the Attorney General.
我们被问到——我被问到我们的案件是否与“9·11”有任何联系，或者与涉及“9·11”的任何个人有关。我所看到的，或者任何处理这个案件的人所看到的，绝对没有任何联系，我们也这样说了。然后，司法部长公开制造了一个人为的联系。
Ashcroft did this in a press briefing a month and a half after the arrests.
阿什克罗夫特在逮捕行动一个半月后的新闻发布会上这样做了。
Three Michigan men suspected of having knowledge of the September 11 attacks were arrested on charges of possessing false documents. In addition to a day planner--
三名密歇根州男子因涉嫌知晓“9·11”袭击事件而被捕，罪名是持有虚假文件。除了那本日程本——
And so I was seeing those manifestations of pure politics.
所以我看到了那些纯粹政治的表现。
Ashcroft had to retract the statement two days later. The judge formally admonished him for violating the gag order, and ended up threatening him with contempt. To Rick, it felt like he and his bosses were out of step with each other, like their goals somehow weren't the same.
阿什克罗夫特两天后不得不撤回了声明。法官正式斥责他违反了封口令，并最终威胁要以藐视法庭罪起诉他。对里克来说，感觉他和他的老板们步调不一致，仿佛他们的目标在某种程度上并不相同。
Their goal was to disseminate information to the American people that we were kicking ass and taking names in the Department of Justice, in the war on terror. I thought, that's unmitigated bull- [BLEEP].
他们的目标是向美国人民传播信息，证明我们在司法部，在反恐战争中表现出色。我想，那是纯粹的胡扯。
Meanwhile, Rick thought Justice Department headquarters in Washington-- what's known as Main Justice-- wasn't giving him the resources, or personnel, or logistical support he needed to prosecute this new kind of terrorism case. Sometimes they seemed clueless to him, or completely incompetent, like when he asked them for another lawyer-- a terrorism expert-- to put on his team.
与此同时，里克认为华盛顿的司法部总部——即所谓的主司法部——没有提供他起诉这种新型恐怖主义案件所需的资源、人员或后勤支持。有时在他看来，他们简直一无所知，或者完全无能，比如当他要求他们派遣另一名律师——一名恐怖主义专家——加入他的团队时。
I mean, my belief was that at the terrorism and violent crime section you can get an expert on prosecuting terrorism-related cases, and I was wrong. There were no genuine experts there in terrorism. You know, it was a shock to see how little those folks knew.
我的意思是，我相信在恐怖主义和暴力犯罪部门，你可以找到一名起诉恐怖主义相关案件的专家，但我错了。那里根本没有真正的恐怖主义专家。你知道，看到那些人知道得那么少，真是令人震惊。
Finally DC did assign another attorney.
最终华盛顿确实指派了另一名律师。
The attorney was a good guy, wanted to work hard. But he was from the tax division. So to me it was mind boggling. As far as I could tell, there were no violations of federal income tax.
这位律师是个好人，愿意努力工作。但他来自税务部门。所以对我来说这太不可思议了。据我所知，这里没有违反联邦所得税的行为。
To give you a sense of how personal these fights could get, here's Jeff Breinholt again, the guy at main justice who was helping formulate these new terrorism cases.
为了让你感受一下这些争吵有多个人化，这位是杰夫·布莱恩霍尔特，那位在主司法部帮助制定这些新恐怖主义案件的人。
If he's using a tax attorney as a way to describe somebody who is not prepared, he's basically condemning me as well, because that's what I am. And most of the people who we brought in to the counter-terrorism business after 9/11 were people who were very specialized in financial techniques. That was exactly what this case needed, I think.
如果他用“税务律师”来描述一个没有准备好的人，他本质上也是在谴责我，因为我就是干这个的。9/11之后我们带入反恐领域的大多数人，都是在金融技术方面非常专业的人。我认为这正是这个案件所需要的。
That response is astonishing to me. If the then-- I think-- acting chief of the terrorism and violent crime section doesn't understand a non financial terrorism related case, then I think that speaks for itself.
这种回应让我感到惊讶。如果当时——我认为是——恐怖主义和暴力犯罪部门的代理负责人连非金融类的恐怖主义相关案件都不懂，那么我认为这不言自明。
There were many squabbles like this, over things that were both petty and sort of fundamental. They couldn't even agree on what kind of help was helpful. And really, since it was a new kind of prosecution strategy, nobody could know for sure.
像这样的争执有很多，关于琐碎的，也关于基本原则的。他们甚至无法就什么样的帮助才算有用达成一致。而且说实话，由于这是一种新的起诉策略，谁也无法确定。
There's a class of prosecutor that other federal prosecutors sometimes call true believers. For them everything is black and white. One described himself to a researcher this way: "We believe in the cause of justice. People look down on us for our enthusiasm, but we leave no stone unturned." That's like Rick. Anyone getting in the way of his case was an enemy of the cause. And Washington was getting in his way.
有一类检察官，其他联邦检察官有时称他们为“真正信徒”。对他们来说，一切都是非黑即白的。其中一人这样向研究人员描述自己：“我们相信正义事业。人们因为我们的热情而看不起我们，但我们不遗余力。”里克就是这样的人。任何妨碍他办案的人都是事业的敌人。而华盛顿正在妨碍他。
Even the wording of the indictment was reason for a fight. An indictment lists the formal charges in a case. It's what the grand jury votes on. But Rick says Main Justice tried to sensationalize the indictment by adding references to Al Qaeda documents found in training camps in Afghanistan, stuff he says had nothing to do with his case. It was as if they'd forgotten the rules of evidence. He felt he was being micromanaged by bureaucrats he was coming to respect less and less.
即使是起诉书的措辞也是争吵的理由。起诉书列出了案件的正式指控。这是大陪审团投票决定的。但里克说主司法部试图通过增加对在阿富汗训练营发现的基地组织文件的引用来炒作起诉书，他说这些东西与他的案件毫无关系。就好像他们忘记了证据规则一样。他觉得他正在被那些他越来越不尊敬的官僚们微观管理。
My dad always used to say never trust a man whose ass is wider than his shoulders, and that's good advice. It is. It's good advice. And it was like, you know, Jesus Christ, what's the plan here?
我父亲常说，永远不要相信一个屁股比肩膀宽的男人，这是好建议。确实是。这是个好建议。当时的感觉就是，天哪，这到底是什么计划？
In the end, Washington demanded changes to the indictment that the Detroit office didn't make, so Main Justice felt Rick wasn't following orders. Rick felt Main Justice was meddling.
最终，华盛顿要求修改底特律办公室并未做出的起诉书，所以主司法部认为里克没有听从指挥。里克觉得主司法部是在干预。
Things got so tense that a couple of senior officials from Washington, including the new chief of the entire counter-terrorism section-- a guy named Barry Sabin-- flew out to Michigan for a face-to-face meeting about the case. And that's where the relationship went from bad to much worse. Here's Rick.
情况变得如此紧张，以至于华盛顿的几位高级官员，包括整个反恐部门的新负责人——一个叫巴里·萨宾（Barry Sabin）的人——飞往密歇根，就该案进行面对面会议。就在那里，关系从糟糕变得更糟了。这是里克。
This was not a pleasant meeting. It was a constant in your face challenge to why we did things the way we did them. And after answering the question regarding the particular way a count was charged a number of times-- I thought-- he asked me again, well, where did you get this from. Where did you get this from. And in a fit of exasperation, in a not very prudent manner, I told him that I pulled it out of my ass. And he looked at the US Attorney, who was devoid of words at the time, and then the US Attorney looked at me and told me that was unprofessional, which I agreed it was. And during the course of the conversation, again, I again imprudently told him that I would like five minutes alone with him, preferably in an alley. Which again didn't go over too big.
那不是一次愉快的会议。他们不断地质问我们为什么要那样做。在多次回答有关某项指控是如何被起诉的问题后——我是这么认为的——他又问我，你是从哪弄来的？你是从哪弄来的？在极度恼火之下，我以一种不太谨慎的方式告诉他，我那是瞎编的（pulled it out of my ass）。他看着当时一言不发的联邦检察官，然后联邦检察官看着我，告诉我那是不专业的，我也同意确实如此。在谈话过程中，我再次不谨慎地告诉他，我想和他单独谈五分钟，最好是在小巷里。这又没取得什么好结果。
Bear in mind, Barry Sabin at the time is the chief of counter-terrorism section, so that's no small thing.
请记住，巴里·萨宾当时是反恐部门的负责人，所以这可不是小事。
Again, Jeff Breinholt.
还是杰夫·布莱恩霍尔特。
It was not a good way to be in dealing with your headquarters component, is to make them feel unwelcome. It's a very unfortunate thing when things get to that point, but I think there was some sense of the time that this case is something we should not have approved.
处理与总部部门的关系，不应该采取那种让他人感到不受欢迎的方式。当事情发展到那一步是非常不幸的，但我认为当时有一种感觉，即这个案件是不应该被批准的。
Because of the personal issues or because of the substance of the case?
是因为个人问题，还是案件的内容？
Personal issues. The trust issue is whether or not this case would be handled the way we wanted it to be.
个人问题。信任问题在于，这个案件是否会按照我们希望的方式来处理。
On March 18, 2003, exactly a year and a half after the arrests, and the same day US forces started bombing Iraq, jury selection began. By this time a fourth defendant, the alleged ringleader of the cell, had been added to the case.
2003年3月18日，距离逮捕行动正好一年半，也就是美军开始轰炸伊拉克的同一天，陪审团选择开始了。此时，第四名被告，即该小组所谓的头目，已被加入案件中。
The evidence was almost all circumstantial. Things like the day planner with the suspicious sketches. But there was a lot of it, and each scrap was aggressively contested.
证据几乎全是间接的。比如那些带有可疑草图的日程本。但证据很多，而且每一条都受到了激烈的争议。
It wasn't one of those trials where one side seemed clearly in the right and the other in the wrong. Both sides seemed credible, which was especially strange, because often their explanations for what the evidence meant, or where it came from, couldn't even be reconciled. For instance, there was this homemade videotape found in the apartment, which the government claimed was shot by would-be terrorists casing Las Vegas and Disneyland for places to attack. The defense claimed the tape was shot by some Tunisian students goofing around on holiday.
那并不是那种一方似乎明显正确、另一方明显错误审判。双方看起来似乎都可信，这尤其奇怪，因为他们对证据含义或来源的解释往往甚至无法调和。例如，公寓里发现了自制的录像带，政府声称是由想成为恐怖分子的人拍摄的，他们在考察拉斯维加斯和迪士尼乐园，寻找袭击地点。辩方声称录像带是由一些在度假时瞎胡闹的突尼斯学生拍摄的。
In the Disneyland part, there's this shot of a pond with some ducks swimming along. Someone sings a little song.
在迪士尼乐园的部分，有一个镜头是一个池塘，几只鸭子游过。有人唱了一首小曲。
According to Rick's translator, the words to the song were something like:
根据里克的翻译，这首歌的歌词大概是：
[BLEEP] them. [BLEEP] the Americans. Kill them and throw them there. Bury them there.
去死吧，美国人。杀了他们，扔在那里。把他们埋在那里。
According to the defendant's lawyer Rick Helfrick:
根据被告律师里克·赫尔弗里克（Rick Helfrick）：
They're singing a song about ducks.
他们在唱一首关于鸭子的歌。
So it was either kill the Americans or here ducky, ducky. And so on through the trial. The trial went on for nine weeks, and in the end, the jury convicted two of the defendants-- Koubriti and the accused ringleader-- of the most serious charge, material support to terrorists. A third guy they found guilty of document fraud, and the fourth, they decided was innocent. All in all, a good day for the justice department.
所以要么是“杀了美国人”，要么是“小鸭子，过来吧”。审判就这样持续了九周。最终，陪审团裁定两名被告——库布里蒂和被指控的头目——犯有最严重的指控，即向恐怖分子提供物质支持。第三个人被判犯有文件欺诈罪，第四个人被认定无罪。总而言之，这对司法部来说是个好日子。
Attorney General Ashcroft announced the verdict, saying every victory in the courtroom brings us closer to our ultimate goal-- victory in the war on terrorism.
司法部长阿什克罗夫特宣布了裁决，称法庭上的每一次胜利都让我们离终极目标更近一步——赢得反恐战争的胜利。
You'd think Rick would be the toast of the justice department. He'd worked incredibly hard on this case for years, and finally, he'd won it for the government. The first jury convictions in a post 9/11 terrorism trial. Instead, he got a talking to from the top guy in Detroit, the US Attorney. Here's Rick.
你可能会认为里克会成为司法部的宠儿。他为这个案子辛苦工作了多年，最终为政府赢得了胜利。这是“9·11”后首起恐怖主义审判的首次陪审团定罪。相反，他却受到了底特律最高领导——联邦检察官的训话。这是里克。
He said to me, "I've been ordered to reprimand you." I said, by whom? He said Washington. For what? For the lack of communication between you and Washington. And I said OK. And he said "OK, I can do it in a number of ways." I said all right. And he said, "But I'm going to verbally reprimand you. I'm verbally reprimanding you." I said, OK. Thank you. And went on my way.
他对我说，“我接到命令要谴责你。”我说，谁下的命令？他说华盛顿。为了什么？为了你和华盛顿之间缺乏沟通。我说好的。他说“好的，我可以有很多种方式。”我说好吧。他说，“但我会口头谴责你。我是在口头谴责你。”我说，好的。谢谢。然后我就走开了。
So there were a lot of ruffled feathers after the case. And at that point in time, when things were just starting to calm down, this contact with the senator comes up.
所以案件结束后有很多不满情绪。就在事情开始平静下来的时候，与这位参议员的接触发生了。
This contact with the senator managed to re-ruffle every feather that had been smoothed, because it wasn't just any senator. It was Charles Grassley, republican from Iowa. Let's just say if the Justice Department had its own deck of most wanted cards depicting Capitol Hill enemies, this guy's face would have been on it. Grassley was known, and still is, as a champion of government whistle blowers, and he'd been scrapping with the Justice Department for many years.
与参议员的这次接触设法重新激起了每一根刚被抚平的羽毛，因为他不是普通的参议员。他是爱荷华州的共和党人查尔斯·格拉斯利（Charles Grassley）。我们可以说，如果司法部有自己的一套描绘国会山敌人的“通缉令”扑克牌，这张脸肯定会在上面。格拉斯利一直以政府举报人的拥护者而闻名，他多年来一直与司法部争斗。
When Rick got the call from Grassley's staffers, Grassley was four months into yet another nasty fight. Because the DOJ wouldn't allow a couple of FBI employees to talk freely to Congress, Grassley was blocking nominations to some top positions inside Justice. But Rick knew none of this, and anyway, that's not why the Grassley staffers had called him. They just wanted to talk about the sleeper cell case, for information for a hearing they were putting together about terrorism and document fraud for the Senate Finance Committee, which Grassley chaired.
当里克接到格拉斯利工作人员的电话时，格拉斯利正在进行另一场令人讨厌的争斗。因为司法部不允许几名FBI员工自由地与国会交谈，格拉斯利正在阻挠司法部内部一些高级职位的任命。但里克对此一无所知，而且无论如何，那也不是格拉斯利的工作人员给他打电话的原因。他们只是想讨论“沉睡者小组”案，为他们准备的关于恐怖主义和文件欺诈的听证会收集信息，该听证会由格拉斯利主持的参议院财政委员会举行。
After talking to Rick for a bit, they asked him to testify at the hearing. And while all this might sound perfectly innocent to you and me, the idea that Rick might cooperate with the Justice Department's arch enemy, even on the topic as neutral as document fraud, really irritated Rick's bosses. He got a call from a senior Justice official who told him these requests are supposed to go through Main Justice in Washington.
和里克聊了一会儿后，他们请他在听证会上作证。虽然这一切对你我来说听起来完全无害，但里克可能与司法部的死敌合作的想法，即使是在文件欺诈这样中立的话题上，也真的激怒了里克的上司。他接到了一名司法部高级官员的电话，对方告诉他这些请求应该通过华盛顿的主司法部进行。
And then he told me, Grassley's no friend of ours, and he used some choice words. And I think I said, "whatever."
然后他告诉我，格拉斯利可不是我们的朋友，他还用了几个精选的词汇。我想我说的是，“随便吧”。
"Whatever" wasn't going to cut it. There was a strict protocol to this stuff, and Rick wasn't following it. Prosecutors in his position simply do not testify before Congress. That was the job with the bigger guns, the US attorneys themselves, or the top guys in DC. Misreading the politics of this situation, ignoring the office politics completely, was about to have much more serious consequences for Rick than he understood.
“随便吧”可没用。这类事情有严格的程序，而里克没遵守。在他这个位置的检察官根本不应该在国会前作证。那是更有权力的人的工作，比如联邦检察官本人，或者是华盛顿的高层。误判这种局势的政治性，完全无视办公室政治，即将给里克带来比他想象中严重得多的后果。
Rick's supervisor in Detroit, Keith Corbett, called him.
里克在底特律的上司基思·科贝特（Keith Corbett）给他打了电话。
He told me that whatever I did really stoked the fires, and that they were talking about firing me. That they believed that I was off the reservation. Off the reservation. I said, Jesus Christ, I helped build the damn reservation, and now I'm off it? Well, how'd I get off it? Because they kicked me off it.
他告诉我，无论我做了什么，确实火上浇油了，他们正在讨论解雇我。他们认为我“脱离了预定路线”（off the reservation）。脱离预定路线。我说，天哪，我帮着建立这该死的“预定路线”，现在我脱离了它？好吧，我怎么脱离的？因为他们把我踢出来了。
Two days later, Rick was subpoenaed to testify before congress. He couldn't very well ignore a subpoena, but on the other hand, he could maybe fight the subpoena. The Justice Department had done that in the past. Rick called Keith Corbett for guidance. They don't talk to each other any more, but at the time, they were still friends. Here's Keith.
两天后，里克被传唤到国会作证。他不能完全无视传票，但另一方面，他也许可以反抗传票。司法部过去曾这样做过。里克打电话给基思·科贝特寻求指导。他们不再交谈了，但在当时，他们还是朋友。这是基思。
And I said Rick, why don't you come in the office on Monday morning, and we'll call Main Justice, and we'll see how we're going to handle this. Rick said , I can't do that. I've got to catch a plane. I said Rick, you don't have to catch a plane. I mean, you're supposed to testify on Tuesday afternoon. And I said come in in the morning. We'll figure out what the Department wants you to do. He said, I can't do that; I've got to take the first flight out. I said, I don't understand that.
我说里克，为什么周一早上不来办公室，我们给主司法部打个电话，看看我们怎么处理这件事。里克说，我做不到。我得赶飞机。我说里克，你没必要赶飞机。我的意思是，你应该在周二下午作证。我说早上过来吧。我们会弄清楚部门希望你做什么。他说，我做不到；我得搭最早的一班飞机离开。我说，我不明白。
I think it was, you know, it was putting your thumb in everybody's eye. I mean, the Department, the US Attorney here. If you know you're not supposed to do something and you go ahead and do it because you want to do it, to me it's like, "I don't know what they're so upset about." Well, you ought to know what they're upset about. So I think that that was a significant event, in terms of the perception by the administration as to where Rick was and whether he was totally out of control, and just going off on his own tangent.
我想那是，你知道，那是打所有人的脸。我的意思是，部门，这里的联邦检察官。如果你知道你不应该做某事，但你还是做了，因为你想做，对我来说就像是，“我不知道他们为什么那么不安。”好吧，你应该知道他们为什么不安。所以我认为这是一个重大事件，关于政府对里克的看法，以及他是否完全失控，只是在走自己的偏锋。
The truth of it was Rick wanted to testify. He'd won this big case and all he got was a reprimand. So he flew to Washington. The night before the hearing, he had a private meeting with Senator Grassley. The way Rick tells it, it was supposed to be just a quick introduction, a pro forma courtesy before the next day's hearing. But almost immediately Rick found himself talking about all the things his bosses didn't want him talking about-- the in-fighting, the mismanagement-- to the very man they didn't want him talking to.
事实是，里克想作证。他赢了这么大一个案子，得到的却只有一次训诫。所以他飞往华盛顿。在听证会的前一天晚上，他与格拉斯利参议员进行了一次私人会面。按照里克的说法，这本应只是一个简单的介绍，在第二天听证会之前的一种例行礼节。但几乎立即，里克发现自己开始谈论那些他的老板们不希望他谈论的事情——内斗、管理不善——的对象，正是他们最不希望他接触的人。
He shook my hand and then asked me a question or two. And when I hesitated, I think he understood that there was more there.
他握了握我的手，然后问了我一两个问题。当我犹豫时，我想他明白了还有更多内容。
So what did you say to him?
那你对他说了什么？
I told him that-- when he asked me did you have all the resources you needed, and I said absolutely no, we did not. Did you have the manpower you needed? No we did not. He was genuinely stunned, at least that was my impression.
我告诉他——当他问我你是否有你需要的所有资源时，我说绝对没有，我们没有。你有你需要的人力吗？没有，我们没有。他确实感到震惊，至少我的印象是这样。
The meeting ended up going on for a very long time, and I think he cancelled what he had at 5:15, and he asked me some pointed questions regarding the way the trial proceeded.
会面最终持续了很长时间，我想他取消了5:15的安排，并就审判过程询问了一些尖锐的问题。
Mr. Convertino, we'll begin with your testimony. First I want to--
康韦蒂诺先生，我们先从你的证词开始。首先我想——
In the hearing room the next morning, a bunch of people from Justice sat themselves down behind Rick, within earshot. The move, he says, was meant to throw him off.
第二天早上在听证室里，一群司法部的人坐在里克后面，在听力范围内。他说，此举旨在让他分心。
Sir, this case started--
先生，这个案子开始于——
Make sure your microphone's on, please.
请确保你的麦克风打开。
Yes sir.
是的，先生。
And maybe--
也许——
You have to pull it up closer to you.
你必须把它拉得离你近一点。
And maybe just a little bit closer. Yes, go ahead.
也许再近一点。是的，继续。
Thank you Mr. Chairman, and good morning, sir. Sir, this case started in--
谢谢主席先生，早上好，先生。先生，这个案子开始于——
During his testimony, Rick didn't utter one word from his conversation the day before with Grassley. He says he never had any intention of complaining publicly, and he told Grassley so. Instead he just talked about the evidence in the case. Stuff like this.
在作证过程中，里克没有吐露半个字关于前一天与格拉斯利谈话的内容。他说他从没打算公开抱怨，他也这样告诉过格拉斯利。相反，他只谈论了案件的证据。比如这些东西。
They talked about acquiring shoulder-held missiles to shoot down airplanes.
他们谈到了获取肩扛式导弹来击落飞机。
And this.
还有这个。
They referred to Las Vegas, Mr Chairman, as the city of Satan.
主席先生，他们把拉斯维加斯称为“撒旦之城”。
And this.
还有这个。
Oh, Allah, kill them all. Don't give them any-- don't leave them any alive, oh Allah. Be without them, whoever believes--
噢，安拉，杀了他们所有人。不要给他们任何——不要留活口，噢安拉。不论是谁相信他们——
If anything, it was actually what Grassley said that got Rick into more hot water.
如果说有什么影响，其实是格拉斯利所说的话让里克陷入了更深的麻烦。
Mr. Convertino, I think you are a model public servant, and as far as I'm concerned, you should be hailed as a hero.
康韦蒂诺先生，我认为你是公共服务的典范，据我所知，你应该被誉为英雄。
I could hear people behind me commenting. So I cringed when he said it, myself, because I knew that any time-- the more that type of language was being used, the worse it was going to be for me when I got back to Detroit.
我能听到背后的人在评论。所以我自己听了这话都觉得退缩，因为我知道无论何时——那种语言用得越多，当我回到底特律时，对我就越糟糕。
Unfortunately for Rick, there was a lot more of that talk, particularly after Grassley let fly this theatrical flourish.
不幸的是，对里克来说，那种话还有很多，特别是在格拉斯利挥舞着这种戏剧性的辞藻之后。
I also want to note that federal law prohibits any retaliation or any discrimination against any person who testifies to the Congress, 18 USC Section 1505. I certainly don't expect there to be repercussions, because Mr. Convertino is here to explain how Justice Department is winning the war on terrorism.
我还想指出，联邦法律禁止对任何向国会作证的人进行报复或歧视，18 USC Section 1505。我当然不期望会有任何反响，因为康韦蒂诺先生是来解释司法部是如何赢得反恐战争的。
What's strange is that that's exactly true. Nobody was publicly embarrassed. The Justice Department itself couldn't have scripted it better. Rick even threw in an Al Qaeda reference. And Grassley didn't launch any investigation. But Rick's testimony violated the way things are done at the Justice Department. So just by breaching protocol in this flagrant way, he'd gone from being an irritant to an outright traitor.
奇怪的是，这完全是事实。没有人受到公开羞辱。司法部自己也不可能写出更好的剧本。里克甚至还抛出了一个基地组织的引用。格拉斯利也没有发起任何调查。但里克的证词违反了司法部行事的方式。所以仅仅通过这种公然破坏协议的方式，他从一个令人恼火的人变成了一个彻底的叛徒。
According to Rick, it wasn't just because he'd testified. It was because his bosses now became convinced that he'd been tattling to Grassley all through the case, complaining secretly for months about how Justice had mishandled the whole thing. Rick couldn't persuade them it wasn't true.
据里克说，这不仅仅是因为他作证了。这是因为他的老板们现在坚信，他在整个案件审理过程中一直向格拉斯利告密，几个月来一直在秘密抱怨司法部是如何处理这件事的。里克无法说服他们这不是事实。
When I came back to the Detroit, it was as if I shot everyone's dog in the office. I was a pariah, and it was clear to me that their motivations now were to punish me.
当我回到底特律时，感觉就像我在办公室里射杀了每个人的狗。我成了贱民，很明显，他们现在的动机是惩罚我。
Six days after Rick got home, Grassley wrote a formal letter to John Ashcroft and the US attorney in Detroit, the first of a slew of letters warning them not to retaliate against Rick for his testimony. That very same day, Rick says the campaign of retaliation began. His bosses told him he was being reassigned to be a duty AUSA, a position they'd created just for him.
里克回家六天后，格拉斯利给约翰·阿什克罗夫特和底特律的联邦检察官写了一封正式信函，这是警告他们不要因里克的证词而报复他的那一连串信函中的第一封。就在同一天，里克说报复行动开始了。他的老板们告诉他，他被重新分配去做一名“值班助理检察官”，这个职位是他们专门为他创造的。
It was as close as they could come to making him a secretary. And that's not all. They told him they'd be reviewing every case he'd ever prosecuted, and they began interviewing judges and other court officials, asking them questions like "Has Convertino ever lied to you?"
这简直就是要把他变成一个秘书。还不止这些。他们告诉他，他们将审查他曾经起诉的每一个案件，并开始采访法官和其他法院官员，问他们诸如“康韦蒂诺有没有对你撒过谎？”之类的问题。
I went to court one time after that. And there was a defense attorney who I had known for some time. I was always on on friendly terms with him. he told me that "There's nothing worse than a crooked prosecutor." Those were the only words he said to me. I mean, crooked was certainly never an adjective that was applied to me in anything I did. It was abundantly clear to me that I wasn't going to go back in there and ever stand up before a jury and say, "My name is Rick Convertino, and I represent the United States of America."
那之后我有一次去法院。有一位我认识很久的辩护律师。我一直和他关系友好。他对我说的唯一的话是，“没有什么比腐败的检察官更糟糕的了。”我所有的行为中，“腐败”这个词从未被用在我身上。我非常清楚，我再也不可能回到那里，站在陪审团面前说：“我叫里克·康韦蒂诺，我代表美利坚合众国。”
Coming up, a prosecutor experiences what it is like to be the defendant, with all the power of the federal government like a huge cannon, now pointed at him. That's in a minute From Chicago Public Radio, and Public Radio international, when our program continues.
接下来，一位检察官体验了作为被告的滋味，联邦政府的所有权力就像一门巨大的大炮，现在正指向他。请在一分钟后回来继续收听。来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, if you're just tuning in, the very strange story of the first terrorism case that came after September 11.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天我们的节目，如果你刚加入，我们将讲述“9·11”后首起恐怖主义案件的非常奇怪的故事。
When Petra Bartosiewicz left off her story before the break, it was fall of 2003. The government had just started its first investigations into the case's prosecutor, Rick Convertino.
佩特拉·巴托谢维奇在休息前结束故事时，时间是2003年秋天。政府刚刚开始对案件检察官里克·康韦蒂诺的行为进行首次调查。
Four months later, someone inside the Department of Justice leaked details of an internal inquiry into Rick's conduct. The Detroit Free Press published a story that included quotes from anonymous Justice officials, and from defense attorneys who knew Rick from the courtroom.
四个月后，司法部内部有人泄露了对里克行为的内部调查细节。《底特律自由报》（Detroit Free Press）发表了一篇报道，其中包括匿名司法官员以及在法庭上认识里克的辩护律师的引语。
That was a front page story in January 17, which was the worst day of my life.
那是1月17日的头版头条，那是我一生中最糟糕的一天。
"Possible misconduct." "Ethical violations." "He believes in trial by ambush." "Rogue prosecutor." That's just some of the stuff printed about Rick. The article said investigators were looking into whether he'd broken the rules in the sleeper cell case, and whether he'd withheld evidence during the trial.
“可能存在不当行为”。“违反道德”。“他相信伏击审判”。“流氓检察官”。这只是关于里克被印出来的部分内容。文章称调查人员正在研究他是否在“沉睡者小组”案中打破了规则，以及他是否在审判期间隐瞒了证据。
I mean, I don't know how to-- what words to describe what it did. It ruined the case. Ruined me, professionally. We used my daughter's senior year in high school, her tuition, and pooled some money together, and sued the bastards.
我的意思是，我不知道该怎么说……用什么词来形容它的后果。它毁了这个案子。在专业上毁了我。我们用女儿高中最后一年的学费，凑了一些钱，起诉了这帮混蛋。
By bastards, he meant former Attorney General John Ashcroft, along with a couple of other Department officials. He sued because the Detroit Free Press story was based on a confidential investigation that clearly was leaked from inside the Justice Department. It's actually against the law to leak information like that.
所谓的混蛋，他指的是前司法部长约翰·阿什克罗夫特，以及其他几名部门官员。他提起诉讼是因为《底特律自由报》的故事是基于一项显然是从司法部内部泄露出来的机密调查。事实上，泄露这类信息是违法的。
What upset Rick the most in the article was not something written about him, but something that every single person I spoke to, even inside the Justice Department, agrees is pretty awful. It has to do with a confidential informant named Marwan Farhat, who Rick enlisted to do translation work for the terrorism prosecution. Here's Stephen Kohn, the lawyer Rick hired to represent him in his civil lawsuit.
在文章中，里克最生气的不是关于他的书写，而是所有我交谈过的人，甚至包括司法部内部的人，都认为相当可怕的事情。这与一名叫马尔万·法哈特（Marwan Farhat）的机密线人有关，里克招募他为反恐起诉工作进行翻译。这是斯蒂芬·科恩（Stephen Kohn），里克聘请代表他进行民事诉讼的律师。
In Rick Convertino's case, they leaked the name of one of his critical informants, a person who was of Middle Eastern descent, currently under cover in counter-- in terrorism related and criminal related investigations. He's actually under cover, and they put his name into the newspapers. And Rick, when he learned this, flipped out, had to rush over and literally had to get him from his house to save his life, and work with the FBI to put him on a plane back to a Middle Eastern nation. "Thank you for your service to the United States." Those people should be in prison, who did that. If I did it, I'd go to jail. Look what they did to try to find in the Valerie Plame thing.
在里克·康韦蒂诺的案件中，他们泄露了他的一名关键线人的名字，一个中东裔的人，目前在反恐和犯罪相关调查中进行卧底。他实际上是在卧底，而他们把他的名字登在了报纸上。里克得知这一点后，惊呆了，不得不冲过去，字面意义上不得不把他从家里带出来以救他的命，并与FBI合作把他送上一架飞回中东国家的飞机。“感谢你为美国服务。”那些做过这件事的人应该进监狱。如果是我干的，我就会进监狱。看看他们在瓦莱丽·普莱姆（Valerie Plame）事件中做了什么。
Rick's lawsuit didn't stop with the leak to the Detroit Free Press. He went on to accuse the Justice Department of mismanaging the war on terror. All the stuff Rick's bosses didn't want him talking to Grassley about was now laid out in a public lawsuit. What's more, he'd hired Kohn, who happens to run the National Whistleblowers Center. In other words, an organization in the same camp as the Justice Department's other constant critic, Senator Charles Grassley. Rick was now-- publicly-- the enemy of his former bosses.
里克的诉讼并没有止步于对《底特律自由报》的泄密。他进一步指控司法部管理反恐战争不善。所有里克的上司不希望他告诉格拉斯利的事情，现在都被写在了一份公开的诉讼书中。更重要的是，他聘请了科恩，碰巧他经营着全国举报人中心（National Whistleblowers Center）。换句话说，是一个与司法部另一位长期批评者查尔斯·格拉斯利参议员站在同一阵营的组织。里克现在公开成为他前老板的敌人。
The Justice Department reacted to the lawsuit the way you might expect. They did what they do best: Opened more investigations. Here's Rick.
司法部对诉讼的反应是你所预料的那样。他们做了他们最擅长的事：开展了更多的调查。这是里克。
There was an investigation from the Executive Office of US Attorneys that was launched, where an attorney from Buffalo, New York, and an attorney from Manhattan were teamed together to come and investigate me. There were investigations by my office of all of my cases. There were investigations by the Public Integrity Section. There were investigations by the Office of Professional Responsibility. There were investigations by the Office of Inspector General. They subpoenaed my law school records, my college records, my high school records. My high school records. They subpoenaed my bank records, my phone records. They talked to over 100 people.
美国检察官执行办公室发起了一项调查，由来自纽约布法罗的一名律师和来自曼哈顿的一名律师联手调查我。我的办公室对我所有的案件进行了调查。公共诚信部门进行了调查。职业责任办公室进行了调查。检察长办公室进行了调查。他们传唤了我的法学院记录、大学记录、高中记录。我的高中记录。他们传唤了我的银行记录、电话记录。他们和100多个人谈过话。
Rick is sure the department expended more money and more manpower on investigating him than they did on the original sleeper cell case.
里克确信，部门在调查他身上投入的金钱和人力，比在最初的“沉睡者小组”案上花的还要多。
Then in December of 2003, six months after the verdict in the sleeper cell case, a very problematic letter surfaced. And this was the moment when all the investigations into Rick started to eat away at the substance of the sleeper cell case itself. The letter had to do with the government's key witness at the trial, a guy named Youssef Hmimmsa who had lived with the defendants, and who said that they were planning violent attacks, that they really were a sleeper cell.
然后在2003年12月，也就是“沉睡者小组”案裁决六个月后，一封非常有问题的信件浮出水面。那一刻，所有对里克的调查开始侵蚀“沉睡者小组”案本身的内容。这封信与政府在审判中的关键证人有关，一个叫优素福·赫米姆斯（Youssef Hmimmsa）的家伙，他曾与被告住在一起，他说他们正在策划暴力袭击，他们确实是一个“沉睡者小组”。
This letter turned out to be the thread that once pulled, unravelled the entire terrorism case. It was big news.
这封信最终成为了一根线头，一旦被拉开，整个恐怖主义案件就解体了。这是一个大新闻。
At issue, a letter the prosecution did not turn over to the defense until last month, well after the trial. It was written by an imprisoned drug gang leader who says that he was in the jail cell next to Hmimmsa. In it, the gang leader claims that Hmimmsa told him that he quote, "Lied to the FBI how he fooled the Secret Service agent on his case." Sources say Justice officials are very concerned about what the judge will decide, and say they admit the prosecution made a mistake.
问题在于检方直到上个月，也就是审判结束后很久才移交给辩方的信。它是由一名被监禁的贩毒团伙头目写的，他说他就在赫米姆斯旁边的牢房里。在信中，团伙头目声称赫米姆斯告诉他，他“向FBI撒了谎，还说他如何愚弄了负责他案件的特勤局探员”。消息人士称，司法部官员对法官将作出的裁定感到非常担忧，并表示他们承认检方犯了一个错误。
The judge ordered a hearing. Rick told him he knew about the letter, but that he and his supervisor Keith Corbett discussed it, and Keith said he didn't need to turn it over. "The only thing I can tell you judge, is it slipped through the cracks," Rick said. Then two of Rick's bosses began contradicting each other about who'd ordered whom to do what. Basically, it was two people from the Justice Department calling each other liars in open court. The judge was so disgusted by the withheld evidence that he ordered the government to do a full review of all the evidence in the case. "This is the most unpleasant task that I've had an almost 14 years as a judge," he said.
法官下令举行听证会。里克告诉他，他知道这封信，但他和他的上司基思·科贝特讨论过，基思说他不需要移交。“法官大人，我唯一能告诉你的是，它漏网了，”里克说。然后里克的两名老板开始互相矛盾，争论谁命令谁做了什么。基本上，这是两名司法部的人在公开法庭上互相指责对方是骗子。法官对隐瞒证据的行为感到如此厌恶，以至于他下令政府对案件中的所有证据进行全面审查。“这是我担任法官近14年来执行的最不愉快的任务，”他说。
The Justice Department appointed a prosecutor named Craig Morford to lead the review. When it was released, the Morford Report was 60 pages long, a litany of accusations against Rick. That he misrepresented the intelligence. That he shopped for expert opinions that bolstered his theory. And most damningly, that he simply didn't turn over evidence that would have been favorable to the defense, breaking the most basic rule prosecutorial conduct.
司法部指派了一名检察官克雷格·莫福德（Craig Morford）领导这次审查。当报告发布时，莫福德报告长达60页，列举了对里克的指控。说他歪曲了情报。他寻求专家意见来支撑他的理论。最糟糕的是，他简单地没有移交对辩方有利的证据，破坏了检察官行为的最基本准则。
With the Morford Report, it was as if the government switched sides, and overnight started working for the defense, questioning the veracity of every major piece of evidence in the case. The day it was filed the defense attorneys were actually seen outside the courthouse, giving each other high fives. They felt vindicated. They thought Rick had been holding back evidence all through the trial.
有了莫福德报告，就像政府换了阵营，一夜之间开始为辩方工作，质疑案件中每一件主要证据的真实性。在该报告提交的那天，人们甚至看到辩方律师在法院外互相击掌。他们感到平反了。他们认为里克在整个审判过程中一直扣留着证据。
For example, they say it was many months into the case before they finally got their hands on the day planner, a central piece of evidence. So then the Morford Report came out, and pretty soon the defense attorneys got over 1,000 pages of documents that the government said they should have had all along. Some of the new information was irrelevant, but still. Rick Helfrick, one of the attorneys who defended Karim Koubriti, said he and his partners were stunned.
例如，他们说在案件开始许多月后，他们才最终拿到日程本，这是一份核心证据。所以当莫福德报告出来后，辩方律师很快就得到了政府称他们应该一直拥有的1000多页文件。其中一些新信息无关紧要，但仍然如此。里克·赫尔弗里克，辩护卡里姆·库布里蒂的律师之一，说他和他的合伙人惊呆了。
If you would have told me that we were going to get turned over to us-- when this was all over-- the amount of material that was turned over to us, that hadn't been turned over, I would have said you were crazy. That that couldn't happen in this district, with this office, or quite frankly, I wouldn't have thought it could happen anywhere in this country. But it did.
如果你当时告诉我，在这一切结束后，我们将会得到——还没被移交的资料数量，我会说你疯了。这种情况不可能发生在这个地区，这个办公室，或者坦白说，我不会认为它可能发生在这个国家的任何地方。但它确实发生了。
One of the main revelations in the 1,000 pages had to do with that blob on the day planner sketch that you heard about earlier in the story. Remember, the sketch was supposedly of the American Air Force base in Incirlik, Turkey. At trial, Rick's witness said that the Air Force intelligence was unanimous about the blob-- that it depicted a hardened bunker used to house fighter jets. But the Morford Report claimed that at least two intelligence officers didn't agree with that analysis and warned Rick that it might not be a bunker, that it might be a map of the Mideast, specifically, the Saudi Arabian peninsula. Here's another defense attorney on the case, Jim Thomas.
那1000页文件中的主要披露之一，与你在故事前面听到的日程本草图上的那个斑点有关。记住，草图据说是土耳其因吉利克美军基地的。在审判中，里克的证人说空军情报部门对这个斑点达成了一致——它描绘的是一个用于存放战斗机的加固地堡。但莫福德报告称，至少有两名情报官员不同意该分析，并警告里克它可能不是地堡，可能是一张中东地图，特别是沙特阿拉伯半岛。这是案件的另一位辩方律师吉姆·托马斯（Jim Thomas）。
He knew that it was a map of the Middle East. It wasn't Incirlik. His own witnesses told him so, and he never told us. I mean, those things are central. Rick Convertino intentionally and deliberately withheld evidence.
他知道那是中东地图。那不是因吉利克。他自己的证人告诉过他，他却从未告诉过我们。我的意思是，这些东西是核心。里克·康韦蒂诺有意且蓄意地隐瞒了证据。
This was the possibility opened up by the Morford Report. Maybe Rick was corrupt, intentionally and deliberately breaking the rules. Rick says there's no question here at all. Not only was he not corrupt, he was fair and thorough, even when it came to identifying that blob. He says he showed it to three different intelligence experts.
这是莫福德报告开启的可能性。也许里克确实腐败了，有意且蓄意地打破规则。里克说这里根本没有任何问题。他不仅没有腐败，而且是公平且彻底的，即使是在识别那个斑点的时候。他说他把它展示给了三位不同的情报专家。
No one told us that that was a map of the Saudi Arabian peninsula. No one ever told me that that was a map of the Saudi Arabian peninsula. They represented it was a hardened bunker. In fact, they represented the specific number of the hardened bunker at the airbase.
没有人告诉我们那是沙特阿拉伯半岛的地图。从来没有人告诉过我那是沙特阿拉伯半岛的地图。他们表示那是一个加固地堡。事实上，他们还表示了空军基地那个加固地堡的具体编号。
Rick rejects the Morford Report. He says the standard Morford is holding him to his ridiculously high, that no other case could survive this kind of scrutiny. And there's not a single mistake he's copping to. And he's not denying the mistakes in a knee jerk way, either. He can explain every discrepancy, and he does. The evidence Morford said was purposely withheld was not, or moreover, didn't exist in the first place. And even if it did, it wasn't significant and so he wasn't required to turn it over. The people Morford claims said things about Rick did not say those things, and in fact in a couple of cases, were asked to lie. I asked him about almost every point in Morford, and he did not budge.
里克拒绝接受莫福德报告。他说莫福德对他要求的标准是高得荒谬的，没有任何其他案件能经受住这种审查。他没有承认任何错误。他也不是以一种膝跳反应的方式否认错误。他可以解释每一个差异，并且他确实做到了。莫福德称被故意扣留的证据其实并没有，或者更确切地说，根本不存在。即使存在，它也不重要，所以他不需要移交。莫福德声称对里克说过那些话的人并没有那样说，事实上在几个案例中，他们被要求撒谎。我就莫福德报告中的几乎每一点询问了他，他都没有让步。
You know, if somebody-- the intimation is-- and sometimes more direct than that-- the accusation is that I drove this personally. That a single and sole Assistant United States Attorney on the ground in Detroit, Michigan, drew his own conclusions regarding the viability of the case, the importance of the case and what all of these pieces of evidence meant.
你知道，如果有人——言外之意是——有时比那更直接——指控是我个人推动了这一切。即在底特律，一名单一且孤独的美国检察官助理就案件的可行性、重要性以及所有这些证据意味着什么得出了他自己的结论。
And that I brought an indictment solely, And that I prosecuted this case solely, is absurd and ridiculous. These repeated allegations, innuendos continue to come and it's obscene that I have to sit here and answer this crap.
而且说我单独提起了起诉，而且说我单独起诉了这个案件，是荒谬和可笑的。这些反复的指控、影射还在继续，我必须坐在这里回答这些垃圾，真是太恶心了。
The allegations in Morford could have been hashed out in a court hearing, where the judge would have decided what to do-- maybe grant a retrial, maybe do nothing. But this didn't happen. Instead, the Justice Department went for the nuclear option. Dan Rather interrupted his live coverage of the Republican National Convention to report it.
莫福德报告中的指控本可以在法庭听证会上进行辩论，法官会决定怎么做——也许批准重审，也许什么都不做。但这没有发生。相反，司法部选择了核选项。丹·拉瑟（Dan Rather）打断了他对共和党全国代表大会的现场直播来报道这件事。
There's been a setback tonight in the war on terror. The Justice Department is now recommending dismissal of convictions in a Detroit terror cell case after admitting to a "quote" "pattern of mistakes and oversights by Federal prosecutors."
今晚反恐战争中出现了一个挫折。司法部现在建议驳回底特律恐怖小组案的定罪，此前他们承认联邦检察官存在“一系列错误和疏忽”。
The government voluntarily undoing its first jury trial terrorism convictions after 9/11, and not even bothering with a do-over. Keith Corbett, Rick's supervisor, couldn't get his head around it. unlike Rick, he agreed with Morford that he and Rick made some mistakes during the trial, though not intentionally. But still, to just dismiss the case like that. And no retrial.
政府自愿推翻其“9·11”后首起陪审团恐怖主义定罪，甚至懒得再审一次。里克的上司基思·科贝特无法理解这一点。与里克不同，他同意莫福德的说法，即他和里克在审判期间确实犯了一些错误，虽然并非故意。但仍然，就这样驳回案件。而且没有重审。
Why? I don't know. You probably could have tried that case again within three or four months. And I don't understand why that happened.
为什么？我不知道。你本来可以在三四个月内重新审理那个案子的。我不明白为什么会发生这种情况。
Rick and his defenders believe the government undid the convictions for one reason. To discredit him, end of story.
里克和他的辩护者认为政府推翻定罪只有一个原因。为了抹黑他，故事结束。
It defies all logic. That's not the way the Department of Justice operates. They fight tooth and nail to defend cases. On every occasion they fight to defend cases on-- I mean wholly egregious cases where discovery was purposefully withheld, they fight. Why not here?
这违背所有逻辑。那不是司法部的运作方式。他们会拼命捍卫案件。在每一个场合，他们都会拼命捍卫案件——我的意思是，即使是证据被故意隐瞒的完全恶劣的案件，他们也会抗争。为什么这里不？
This is one of the most confusing aspects of this whole story. Again, the Justice Department wouldn't talk to me for this report-- so I couldn't ask them directly-- but it does seem out of character, at least in terrorism cases, for the Justice Department to simply fold. Just last year, in the terrorism financing case of the Holy Land Foundation, after two mistrials, the government said it would try the case a third time. The same thing, two mistrials, happened in the case of the Miami Seven. The government plans to retry that case a third time too.
这是整个故事中最令人困惑的方面之一。再说一次，司法部拒绝就这份报告接受我的采访——所以我无法直接问他们——但在恐怖主义案件中，司法部仅仅因为这样就直接“投降”，确实显得不合常理。就在去年，在圣地基金会（Holy Land Foundation）的恐怖主义融资案中，经过两次审判无效后，政府表示将第三次审理该案。同样的事情，两次审判无效，也发生在“迈阿密七人组”案中。政府计划第三次重审该案。
True, neither of these involved accusations of prosecutorial misconduct. But even so, the government's overall position on terrorism cases has been aggressive from start to end. Jeff Breinholt, the former terrorism guy from the Justice Department, believes they probably could have retried the sleeper cell case successfully. And when my producer Sarah Koenig and I asked him about it, he had a hard time explaining why they didn't go back to court.
诚然，这些案件都没有涉及检察官不当行为的指控。但即便如此，政府在恐怖主义案件上的总体立场从始至终都是激进的。曾是司法部恐怖主义部门负责人的杰夫·布莱恩霍尔特认为，他们本可以成功重审“沉睡者小组”案。当我的制片人莎拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）和我问他时，他很难解释为什么他们没有回到法庭。
It potentially could have been a circus environment. And a decision was made to cut the losses.
这可能会变成一个马戏团式的环境。最终决定是止损。
It sounds almost like you're saying they just wanted to be rid of it.
听起来几乎像是在说他们只是想摆脱它。
Yeah.
是的。
What Rick Convertino will say, and what even colleagues who are mad at him will say, is it looks very much as if the Department of Justice sacrificed this case in order to bring him down personally.
里克·康韦蒂诺会说的，甚至是那些对他生气的人也会说的，看起来司法部似乎牺牲了这个案子，只是为了在个人层面上搞垮他。
No, no.
不，不。
OK, why is that not true?
好的，为什么那不是真的？
We sacrifice cases all the time in the interest of justice. In the interest of justice in this case, according to the people who made that decision, we're to walk away from a case where a jury had found somebody guilty. The fact that a case got to this point, it doesn't make this a personal vendetta, or the first time in human history this has ever happened.
我们为了正义的利益牺牲了很多案件。在这种情况下，根据那些做出决定的人的说法，为了正义的利益，我们放弃了一个陪审团已认定某人有罪的案件。案子到了这一步的事实，并不能使这成为个人恩怨，也不是人类历史上第一次发生这种事。
I mean, do you understand from where we sit that it looks kind of extreme for the Department to let it go?
我的意思是，你明白从我们的角度来看，部门放手看起来有点极端吗？
Perhaps. I can see that, but I also think people who think that often don't give the Department credit for doing the right thing.
也许吧。我可以理解这一点，但我也认为，认为这一点的人通常不会归功于司法部做了正确的事。
A year and a half after the sleeper cell convictions were reversed, in the spring of 2006, all the investigations into Rick's conduct finally came to fruition. The Justice Department indicted Rick on criminal charges for suppressing evidence in the sleeper cell case. Now we're at the part of the story Rick calls his:
在“沉睡者小组”案定罪被推翻一年半后的2006年春天，所有对里克行为的调查终于开花结果。司法部以压制“沉睡者小组”案证据的刑事指控起诉了里克。现在我们到了里克所说的部分：
Bogus month-long bull [BLEEP] trial.
长达一个月的垃圾狗屁审判。
If you believe Rick and his lawyer, this was all classic retribution with very suspicious timing. For a federal prosecutor to be criminally indicted in the line of duty is practically unheard of. Not that prosecutors haven't misbehaved. They just don't get called out like this. If anything, the Justice Department has been criticized for years for failing to police its own.
如果你相信里克和他的律师，这完全是典型的报复，时间选择非常可疑。联邦检察官在履行职责时受到刑事起诉几乎是闻所未闻的。并不是说检察官没有犯错。他们只是没有这样被传唤。如果说有什么不同的话，司法部多年来一直因为未能监管自己而受到批评。
Rick says that what was most amazing and dispiriting was that the government was setting out to destroy him and there was nobody to stop them, and no one cared. Though of course, the defendants in the sleeper cell case might say exactly the same thing about him, and about the Justice Department when they were on trial. That there was a political agenda at work. That the evidence against them was viewed in the worst possible light. That no one was giving them the benefit of the doubt.
里克说最令人惊奇和沮丧的是，政府一心要摧毁他，没有人阻止他们，也没有人在乎。当然，“沉睡者小组”案的被告在受审时可能也会对他和司法部说同样的话。说有一个政治议程在发挥作用。说对他们的证据被以最坏的方式看待。说没有人给他们无罪推定的好处。
The criminal trial took place in the same courthouse where Rick prosecuted the terrorism case, an irony that wasn't lost on the accused terrorists. One of them showed up just to watch.
刑事审判发生在里克起诉恐怖主义案件的同一个法院，这种讽刺并没有被那些被指控的恐怖分子忽略。其中一个甚至特意跑来观看。
I walked into that courtroom and the first person that I saw was Karim Koubriti, who was locked on to me, sitting in glory, because the justice system was now transplanting his role for mine. The world was upside down. I could not believe that I was in there as a defendant.
我走进那个法庭，看到的第一个人就是卡里姆·库布里蒂，他死死盯着我，坐在荣耀中，因为司法系统现在正把他的角色移植给我。世界颠倒了。我无法相信我竟以被告的身份出现在那里。
The main charges were obstruction of justice and conspiracy. He faced a potential prison sentence of 30 years. After all the questions raised by the Morford Report, the only criminal misconduct the government thought it could prove in the trial had to do with some photos that weren't turned over to the defense in the sleeper cell case. The government claimed Rick conspired to conceal them. An old friend of Rick's, Greg Stejskal, went to his trial almost every day. He's an attorney and a former FBI agent.
主要指控是妨碍司法和共谋。他面临30年的潜在刑期。在莫福德报告提出的所有问题之后，政府认为在审判中能证明的唯一刑事不当行为，与一些未移交给“沉睡者小组”案辩方的照片有关。政府声称里克密谋隐瞒这些照片。里克的老朋友格雷格·斯泰斯卡尔（Greg Stejskal）几乎每天都去参加他的审判。他是一名律师，也是前FBI探员。
As I sat and listened to the evidence and everything else, I thought, you know, where's the case? There has to be something more here. There has to-- the government would not criminally prosecute Rick based on what I've heard so far. There must be somebody that's going to come in and say "Yeah, I saw Rick look at those pictures, and he told me that we can't let the defense have these pictures," or something.
当我坐着听证据和其他一切时，我想，你知道，案子在哪？这里肯定有更多东西。肯定有……如果政府基于我目前所听到的起诉里克，那是不可能的。肯定有人会进来，说“是的，我看到里克看了这些照片，他告诉我我们不能让辩方拿到这些照片，”或者类似的话。
And I sat through the whole thing, and I got to the end, and I thought, that's it? That's the best they can do? And so the final conclusion I came to was, all right, they're either incredibly stupid, which they're not. Or they deluded themselves into believing that there was something there that wasn't. Almost like a mass hysteria kind of thing.
整个过程我都坐在那里，到了最后，我想，就是这样？这就是他们能做到的最好程度？所以我得出的最终结论是，好吧，他们要么极其愚蠢，但他们并不是。要么他们欺骗自己，相信那里有什么其实不存在的东西。几乎像是群体歇斯底里那样的东西。
It took the jurors less than a day to acquit Rick on all counts.
陪审团用了不到一天时间就裁定里克所有罪名不成立。
So Rick sued Ashcroft. The justice department prosecuted Rick. Koubriti sued Rick. Rick sued the newspaper. Then Rick sued the Justice Department again, and he's considering a third lawsuit against them for malicious prosecution. What are we supposed to think about this whole sorry mess of lawsuits? Was Rick a rogue prosecutor? Was he the victim of a department-wide vendetta?
所以里克起诉了阿什克罗夫特。司法部起诉了里克。库布里蒂起诉了里克。里克起诉了报纸。然后里克又起诉了司法部，并且正在考虑就恶意起诉对他们进行第三次诉讼。对于这整场悲惨的诉讼烂摊子，我们应该怎么想？里克是一个流氓检察官吗？他是部门范围内恩怨的受害者吗？
What seems most likely to me, after spending months talking to all sides trying to figure it out, is this. Rick withheld information in the case that he should have turned over, but what he did was no different than what federal prosecutors do all the time. Withholding exculpatory evidence is the most common mistake prosecutors make at all levels of the justice system. And the reason it's so common is that it's a judgment call. Rick says he didn't think he was breaking the law. He thought he was playing fair. And that's perfectly believable because there's a gray area concerning what evidence you have to turn over.
在我花了几个月与各方交谈试图弄清楚之后，最有可能的是这样。里克在案件中隐瞒了本应移交的信息，但他所做的与联邦检察官一直所做的事情没有什么不同。扣留辩护证据是检察官在司法系统各个层面最常犯的错误。之所以如此普遍，是因为这是一个判断题。里克说他认为自己没有违反法律。他以为自己是在公平竞争。这一点完全可信，因为关于你必须移交什么证据，存在一个灰色地带。
Unfortunately for Rick, he's the rare prosecutor who got scrutinized. Normally the Justice Department stands behind a prosecutor's choices, even questionable ones. But Rick lost that backup, which was the only safety net that ultimately mattered. And he lost that support not because of our national interest, or any high-minded principles of fair play. He lost it because of his attitude. I was surprised to hear one of his old bosses, Jeff Breinholt, admit as much.
不幸的是，里克是罕见的受到严格审查的检察官。通常，司法部会支持检察官的选择，即使是有争议的选择。但里克失去了那种支持，而这最终才是唯一重要的安全网。他失去这种支持不是因为我们的国家利益或任何高尚的公平竞争原则。他失去它是由于他的态度。我惊讶地听到他的一位老上司，杰夫·布莱恩霍尔特，承认了这一点。
That is an important factor. I always laugh when people say-- people try to equate what happened-- how Bill Clinton was treated compared to Richard Nixon. Richard Nixon didn't make it whereas Bill Clinton did. And I always say there's a little secret in politics. It really matters whether people like you. So how you get along with people is going to affect what happens to you. It's going to affect how many people come to bat for you. There's plenty of ways this thing did not have to get to that point, if he had acted differently.
那是一个重要因素。我总是嘲笑人们说——人们试图把所发生的事情进行比较——比尔·克林顿是如何被对待的，与理查德·尼克松相比。尼克松没能成功，而克林顿成功了。我总是说政治中有一个小秘密。人们是否喜欢你真的很重要。所以你如何与人相处将会影响到你身上发生的事情。它会影响有多少人出来支持你。如果他以不同的方式行事，这件事情完全不必发展到那一步。
After all, Rick's immediate supervisor on the terrorism case, Keith Corbett, who co-prosecuted the case with Rick, who was in on every decision, was demoted in the wake of the investigations, but he certainly wasn't indicted. People liked Keith. Keith wasn't threatening to punch out his colleagues.
毕竟，里克在恐怖主义案件上的直接上司基思·科贝特，也就是和里克一起起诉案件、参与每一个决定的人，在调查结束后被降职了，但他当然没有被起诉。人们喜欢基思。基思没有威胁要揍他的同事。
Rick says he doesn't regret anything about the way he handled the case including, he told my producer, mouthing off to his bosses.
里克说他不后悔处理案件的方式，包括他告诉我的制片人，顶撞他的老板们。
You had to know that all these people had egos, and that every time you did that you were burning a bridge.
你一定知道这些人都有自尊心，而且你每次这样做就是在烧毁一座桥。
I did know that. But the bridges that were being burnt were small and inconsequential.
我确实知道。但被烧毁的桥很小，微不足道。
But were they?
但它们真的是吗？
They were. They were and they are to me now, because what are we doing? You take an oath as an Assistant US Attorney, working for the Federal Government in the Department of Justice, for Christ sake. What higher plane can an attorney be on?
它们是。它们曾经是，对我来说现在也是，因为我们到底在干什么？你宣誓担任美国检察官助理，为联邦政府在司法部工作，看在上帝的份上。律师还能处于什么更高的层次？
But, Rick, come on. You'd been in the office. You knew as well as anyone the politics of this office. It just sounds so naive for you to say, like, but we were serving the public good. They're going to come back and slaughter you.
但是，里克，得了吧。你在办公室呆过。你和任何人一样了解这个办公室的政治。你说“但我们在为公共利益服务”听起来太幼稚了。他们会回来屠杀你的。
And they did. They tried. They tried. And you're right. I mean, was it imprudent? Maybe.
他们确实这样做了。他们尝试了。他们尝试了。你是对的。我的意思是，那是不谨慎的吗？也许。
Maybe?
也许？
Well, listen. What you said was naive, I believe. I believe to this day. The first time that I saw it was when I was in Washington DC, and had some early success. I had a case-- the only case I've lost to this day-- was in the early '90s. And when I lost it, the attitude of my coworkers seemed to be that they were happy that I lost the case. And in fact, I raised that issue and was told, yeah, yeah, they are. That was the first time I saw it. And I thought, I don't care if you don't like me.
好吧，听着。我认为你所说的确实很幼稚，直到今天我还这么认为。我第一次看到这一点是在华盛顿特区，并取得了一些早期成功时。我有一个案件——我至今输掉的唯一案件——是在90年代初。当我输掉它时，我同事的态度似乎是他们很高兴我输掉了案子。事实上，我提出了这个问题，并被告知，是啊，是啊，他们确实。那是我第一次看到它。我想，我不在乎你们喜不喜欢我。
It's easy to forget there was a terrorism case under all of this. And maybe either innocent men were convicted or guilty men were freed. To this day, the Justice Department has made a point of not taking a position on this question. They've never said the men weren't terrorists. This in particular angers Karim Koubriti.
很容易忘记这一切之下有一个恐怖主义案件。也许要么是无辜的人被定罪，要么是罪犯被释放。直到今天，司法部都明确表示不对这个问题采取立场。他们从未说过这些人不是恐怖分子。这一点特别让卡里姆·库布里蒂感到愤怒。
They never apologized to me. What, you think I'm a piece of garbage, treating me like that, and just be happy you're out? I don't like to be treated that way, really. And I don't feel justice was done.
他们从未向我道歉。什么，你以为我是垃圾，这样对待我，然后因为你被释放就高兴了？我不喜欢被那样对待，真的。我不觉得正义得到了伸张。
Are you a terrorist?
你是恐怖分子吗？
No, I am not. Sometimes I really ask myself this question. And you guys make me think-- you know, when sometimes you hear stuff about you, you sit and say how you could-- what is this? Is this is joke or something? I never hurt anybody in my life. Anybody. I never even think to hurt anybody in my life. And I don't have any reason to be a terrorist. I am from Morocco. I am not from Palestine. I am not from Afghanistan. I'm not an Iraqi. I really didn't have any bad feelings about the United States. I really don't care about politics. I just want to have a good future, that's the only reason I came to the United States.
不，我不是。有时我真的会问自己这个问题。而你们让我去想……你知道，当你听到关于你自己的事，你坐下来想，这怎么可能……这是什么？这是个玩笑吗？我这辈子从来没伤害过任何人。任何人。我这辈子甚至没想过伤害任何人。我没有任何理由成为恐怖分子。我来自摩洛哥。我不是来自巴勒斯坦。我不是来自阿富汗。我不是伊拉克人。我对美国没有任何坏的感觉。我真的不在乎政治。我只是想有一个美好的未来，这是我来到美国的唯一原因。
So what's terrorist mean, a Muslim? I am a Muslim. If you want to think I'm a terrorist because I'm Muslim, I can't control that. But if you mean terrorist, that somebody was trying to hurt innocent people, I think he is the terrorist.
所以恐怖分子是什么意思，穆斯林吗？我是穆斯林。如果你想因为我是穆斯林就认为我是恐怖分子，我无法控制。但如果你指的是恐怖分子，即某人试图伤害无辜的人，我认为他才是恐怖分子。
Rick's the terrorist, Koubriti says, because he knew all along they weren't terrorists. That's why he's suing Rick now. And I think what enrages Rick the most is that he now lives in a world where someone like Koubriti can accuse him-- a former federal prosecutor-- of being a terrorist. That his credibility has been so eviscerated that he has to defend his most basic beliefs.
库布里蒂说里克是恐怖分子，因为他一直都知道他们不是恐怖分子。这就是为什么他现在要起诉里克。我想让里克最愤怒的是，他现在生活在一个世界里，像库布里蒂这样的人可以指责他——一名前联邦检察官——是恐怖分子。他的信誉已经被剥夺得如此彻底，以至于他不得不为自己最基本的信仰进行辩护。
You think these guys were terrorists?
你认为这些人是恐怖分子吗？
Beyond all peradventure, there's no question in my mind.
毫无疑问，我心中没有任何问题。
For Rick this is the bottom line. His job was to protect people and it was a responsibility he took seriously. He was a soldier in the war on terror, and he believes he accomplished his mission. He shut down a sleeper cell. He prevented the terrorists from striking again.
对里克来说，这是底线。他的工作是保护人们，这是他认真对待的责任。他是反恐战争中的一名士兵，他相信他完成了他的使命。他关闭了一个“沉睡者小组”。他阻止了恐怖分子再次发动袭击。
So I weigh that. What personal cost and professional cost did I pay for what may have been preventing a strike? I think we did a very important thing here.
所以我会衡量这一点。为了可能阻止了一次袭击，我付出了什么样的个人代价和专业代价？我认为我们在这里做了一件非常重要的事情。
Now Rick is a criminal defense attorney. So far he's good at it. Seven for seven. He specializes in law enforcement officers who get in trouble on the job. A state trooper accused of murder. A cop charged with assault. People whose bosses aren't backing them up. These guys come to him, Rick says, because he's been through what they're going through. They know how angry he is, and they want that working for them.
现在里克是一名刑事辩护律师。到目前为止他干得不错。七战七捷。他专门负责处理工作中遇到麻烦的执法人员。一名被控谋杀的州警。一名被控袭击的警察。老板不支持他们的那种人。这些人找他是因为他经历过他们正在经历的事情。他们知道他有多愤怒，并且他们希望那种愤怒能为他们所用。
Petra Bartosiewicz. She's writing a book called The Best Terrorists We Could Find on this and other Justice Department cases in the war on terror. It's coming out in spring, 2009. Our program today and our story about Rick Convertino was produced by Sarah Koenig, with Alex Blumberg, Jane Feltes, Lisa Pollak, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp and Nancy Updike.
佩特拉·巴托谢维奇。她正在写一本书，名为《我们能找到的最好的恐怖分子》（The Best Terrorists We Could Find），内容关于此案以及其他反恐战争中的司法部案件。将于2009年春季出版。我们今天的节目和关于里克·康韦蒂诺的故事由莎拉·科尼格制作，还有亚历克斯·布隆伯格、简·费尔特斯、丽莎·波拉克、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克。
Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Some music in today's show by Pierre Takal. Special thanks today to Bill Davis and Charles De Arman at the National Archives. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. Support for this American Life is provided by the Saab 9-3 family, a sports sedan, sport combi, and all season convertible. Saab, born from jets. Learn more at Saabusa.com
我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德。今天节目中的部分音乐由皮埃尔·塔卡尔（Pierre Takal）创作。今天特别感谢国家档案馆的比尔·戴维斯和查尔斯·迪·阿曼。本节目由国际公共广播电台发行。本节目的支持来自萨博9-3系列，运动轿车、运动旅行车和全季敞篷车。萨博，源自喷射机。在Saabusa.com了解更多。
And by Showtime, bringing a new season of real life stories of television. Namely, the real life stories on the television version of our program: This American Life is now on the air with new episodes Sundays, 10:00. And they repeat pretty much every day of the week. 1-80o- Showtime, or sho.com. WBEC management oversight for a program by our boss Mr. Tory Malatea whose been eyeing both my ass and my shoulders lately with one thing running through his head.
还有Showtime，带来了新一季电视真人故事。也就是我们节目的电视版本中的真人故事：《美国生活》现在正播出新剧集，每周日10点。而且每周差不多每天都会重播。1-800-Showtime，或sho.com。WBEC的管理层监督由我们的老板托里·马拉泰亚（Tory Malatea）负责，他最近一直用一种想法盯着我的屁股和肩膀。
My dad always used to say never trust a man whose ass is wider than his shoulders.
我父亲常说，永远不要相信一个屁股比肩膀宽的男人。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。